There’s a new Game of Thrones spinoff show
in development about Aegon’s Conquest – the
story of how the Targaryens first took over
Westeros. There have been previous attempts
to make an Aegon’s Conquest show, but now
it’s in development with a new writer.
So there are now at least six Game of Thrones
spinoff shows in development. House of the
Dragon Season 2 will air this year. A Knight of
the Seven Kingdoms has been greenlit – about the
adventures of Dunk and Egg. There’s an
animated show in development about the
voyages of the Sea Snake. And there are two
more animated projects in development – one
of these might be The Golden Empire, about
Yi Ti, the Game of Thrones version of China.
There was a sequel show about
Jon Snow in development,
led by Kit Harington. But it’s not clear if
that show is still being made. There was also
a show about Nymeria in development – about
an ancient eastern princess. Finally there’s
a stage show about the tourney of Harrenhal
being made which might open late this year.
We’ve made videos about most of these
stories on our YouTube channel Alt Shift X.